>>Good afternoon.
Welcome to the culminating
event of Fading Footprints.
>>Narrator: It's a big day for King
Middle School's seventh-grade class.
It's the day they present
their class project,
a CD-ROM featuring Maine's endangered
species, to an audience of parents,
teachers, and experts at
Portland's Audubon Society.
>>Boy: First we took research
on the Internet and stuff,
and then after that, we had to
format it right, doing drafts.
It took me about 10
drafts to get this right.
>>Narrator: Producing the CD
was an ambitious undertaking,
especially for a school that
serves the most ethnically
and economically diverse
population in the state,
a school where 28 different
languages are spoken and 60 percent
of students qualify for
free and reduced lunch.
But it's just one of a series
of impressive productions
the school has turned out,
byproducts of a curriculum
designed to bring
out the best in every student.
>>Right now, if I was in a
moat, I would become very ill.
A moat is very polluted.
>>Scott: The model that we
use is expeditionary learning,
outward-bound, so it
focuses on hands-on learning.
We try to integrate science,
social studies, math,
and English with technology,
with artwork,
with community members,
fieldwork, etc.
>>Narrator: The Fading Footprints
CD includes a student-made video
that illustrates the
production process.
>>For the Fading Footprints kickoff,
David Sparks came in
and brought animals.
He talked about the animals'
habitat and how they survive.
Then we started our
research using our laptops.
>>Scott: We don't use
textbooks, per se.
The students can sit here right on
their computers with the air ports,
and we can do a lot of our
research right here in class.
>>We were also using our
library and many books to try
to find some information, and
Internet, we use our laptops a lot.
>>Narrator: Through digital
production, students learn
to collaborate and contribute
their many different talents.
In music class, they recorded
soundtracks for the CD.
In art, they painted
scientifically accurate watercolors
of their animals.
>>It talks about fieldwork,
and they're out
and they're playing
with other fishes.
>>Narrator: And in video-production
class, they made the movie
about the making of the CD.
>>On our winter walk, we learned
about how animals and plants survive
in Maine's harsh climate.
>>David: We're looking at ways for
students to deepen their knowledge
and work with their own knowledge
so that they can become the
authors of their own learning.
All schools should be making
things with their students
that force the students to
show us what they've learned,
and it's in the making of things
that kids actually do their learning.
>>Narrator: To give their
products professional polish,
the school has connected
with local businesspeople,
like print-shop owner
Philip Rhinelander.
>>Now, would these students
take a particular species
and concentrate on that?
>>Yes.
>>The focus started with just
helping them print the newsletter,
and then it turned out, "Gee,
wouldn't it be wonderful
if every kid could take home a book?"
And so we were able to help
them by donating those.
And then we find our
relationship with them is so good
that they'll come in,
"We need CD covers."
"Sure, we'll do them for you."
It's a synergy that just
seems to have come together.
To be part of that is very exciting.
>>So, we have Kayla filming,
and we have like three
angles of her filming.
>>Narrator: The school has also hired
an accomplished documentary filmmaker
to help students improve
the quality of their work.
>>Huey: My mission is to
show them how to make,
I guess you'd say good movies, movies
that rise above just being imitations
of everything they've seen.
>>I think what matters more is
what the flow of the video is.
>>Huey: Having an audience,
I think, is great.
I mean, it puts you on the line.
It's not just like, "Well,
I meant to do this," or,
"I was going to do this,"
or, "If you let me tell you,
you can really understand it."
So I think that is an interesting
part of the educational component
of this, and hearkens back
to this thing of quality.
You want to stand up there.
You want to show them
your best stuff.
And so that permeates
the entire process.
>>Narrator: Since implementing
the project-based curriculum,
King principal Mike McCarthy
has seen the test scores
of King's diverse student body
go from the bottom one-third
to the top one-third in the state.
>>Michael: I've heard people
describe what a gifted
and talented classroom
would look like.
It should include field experiences,
and it should include technology.
It should include independent work.
It should include work
that is in depth.
Well, that's basically what
our school is [Applause].
>>Scott: Every kid has
their own finish line
and some kids might
have done seven pages
and some kids might have
done three paragraphs.
That's okay.
They have done their work.
They're on the CD.
They have completed what they can
do, and it's the best they can do.
>>Michael: Our whole goal is that
every student here can have access
to high-quality learning and
produce high-quality products.
One kid said, "Nobody feels stupid
around here anymore," and I think
that was one of our
highest achievements.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.